what was uh for you like growing I mean
obviously you mentioned a lot of the
hypnotized mind like that's a kind
of a generation before you yeah
where what I mean that says a lot about
their reach in terms of just like
their influence and the music was
incredible but like how big of a fan of
the hypnotized mind were you
growing up or was it kind of like before
your time yeah that was before my time
and like I grew a beautiful I grew up
Catholics I like it was a lot of gospel
music and my mom like they have Catholic
Gospel music no I mean I don't think I
like gospel music I didn't have never
heard a Catholic Gospel music I mean
like the church I don't know it's real
like quite a lot of prayers stand up
send down but it's like all black
churches South Memphis right like that's
a cat it's a Catholic Church yeah but
the choir we get down though July any
other Baptist right all that other stuff
so you grew up in the church pretty
conservative
yeah my folks are streaked on me yeah
what do they feel about you being like a
rapper now and doing your thing when my
stepdad he always worrying all the time
like just be safe and watch out for
strangers don't do this don't do that
but my mom she real cool and support
right how old are you 25. okay so you're
you're not like you you've lived some
life yeah I got it got some season on me
um how long have you been rapping for
like five six years five or six years
yeah at what point in time did you feel
like there was like a breaking point
where you realize that you could really
take it serious and like you know maybe
make some money
uh probably around like 2018 I'll say
like
stuff just started progressing for me
like me different producers and they're
working all this stuff so once I really
started seeing
results from what I was doing this when
I was like okay this could really take
out for me what's it like working with
the hit Cape guy because he's got you
know he's he's a guy hey he he's Joe
Jackson which I don't know he's he's fun
but he crazy like when he's trying to
work his sign to work Joe Jackson is
Michael Jackson's dad yeah so probably a
not a great comparison
yeah but nah he really be like hard on
us and stuff but like in a good way like
we're in the studio he'll be like I know
y'all could do better than that and like
let's stop playing around let's get this
done right but when it's time to play
it'd be time to play that's fair